Một ngày 11 tham ột, nhiều hạn hằng không có thể tiếp tục tránh cùng phận 2 nước Iran và Iraq,
dù tế Iran đã mở lại sau gần 5 giờ đóng cửa,
sự việc phản anh tâm li tận trọng trước,
mùi cơ leo thang cao tham, giữ Iran và Mỹ.
Theo dựng liệu theo dõi trên bài,
các hạn hằng không châu Âu, nhiều lúc hằng xa,
with this airway, but with air,
richy, các trên bài vòng qua chúng, và hạn gà niết thang,
lứt cùng này của bàn and quên gáo,
để hình các hạn hằng không đứng lại chẳng bài qua không phận Iran.
Trước đó Iran đã tạm nắm không phận của Mỹ của tham ột,
giữa lòng gà khả năng đối đầu của sự với Mỹ.
Phía Mỹ cũng cho dữ bất một số nhận sự khỏi các căn cửa chúng đông,
nhiều bệnh pháp phòng người, việc bị tấn công.
Lên quan tới khả năng sảy ra xung đồ của sự hành lốc.
Ngay bị bún tham ột, tầm thông, mình tôi đang tròm cho biết,
ông được thông báo rằng,
mức độ bạo lực tròm trên dịch trên áp được tình tại Iran đang rằng,
ông đồng thời tiên rằng,
giới trước tế Iran không có kế hoạch hành quyết người được tình,
tế bài ông tròm bật không lại bỏ hạn lăng hành động của sự.
Về phía Tây Iran, ngoài trưởng Abbas Aroxi khẳng địch,
Iran không tìm giềm trên trang, như sẵn sản đập trả,
nếu bị Mỹ tấn công,
trên thông nhận lốc Iran của phụ nhận thông tin,
một số người biểu tình chè tôi sẽ bị tên áp tự hình.